Film Courage: I'm wondering if we can start out where
you were working at was at the YWCA
or YMCA okay...and it sounds like you
were doing a fantastic and they wanted
to promote you again and if we could
start out on that story because I find
it so fascinating. Christine Conradt, screenwriter: And so this is a lot
earlier and obviously my career and I
graduate from film school. I went to USC
kind of thought like everybody does when
they graduate from film school that
you're gonna graduate with like a
three-picture deal and that isn't really
how it works and so while I was in
college I had worked as a lifeguard and
kind of an aerobics instructor and at a
YMCA and they kept promoting me and
every time someone would quit they would
say well do you want to learn how to do
this job and I always said yes and so
eventually I worked my way up to program
director and ultimately executive senior
Senior Program Director which is right
under the executive director so the
executive director heads up a branch and
then there's a Senior Program Director
or two and then all the program
directors under that person so I had
been working there and it was I mean it
was fine it wasn't what my degree was in
and so at one point finally I thought
well you know I had a lot of school debt
going to USC obviously I was like I
think I think I was about 6070 thousand
dollars in debt at that point and my
executive director came to me and said
you know we'd really love to give you
your own branch but we need a five-year
commitment from you to do that and they
were gonna pay me over a hundred
thousand dollars a year and that would
have been great going towards my debt
and so I said well let me let me think
about that so I went home that night and
I really thought about you know what I
wanted to do with my life I had gone to
film school I really hadn't given it the
chance that it deserved and so I thought
well I'm this much in debt anyway I'm
gonna I'm gonna take the chance on being
a screenwriter and so I went back the
next day and I thanked the executive
director for that offer and said you
know I
accept it and also I have to put my
two-week notice in because I need to
take six months off and I'm gonna take
out a loan to live on and I'm gonna live
my life as a writer and if it doesn't
work I can come back and I'll let go of
that dream forever but if it does work I
owe it to myself to give myself this
chance to actually become a screenwriter
so I did exactly that she was not happy
that I was leaving but um but I did put
my notice in and I did take out a loan
to live on and during that time I wrote
two screenplays I never sold either of
them but they both got me work and they
got me work and then those got me work
and it actually ended up being really
the beginning of my career as a
screenwriter
Wow so many questions I know right
because and there's so many little
interesting parts of that and scary
parts too and I've known a few people
that have been stuck with the debt doing
something similar yeah so I know that is
a risk it's a huge risk and I would
never encourage anyone to emulate that
in any way for me for me it worked and I
think because I'd already spent the four
years in school you know kind of gearing
myself up towards this career and I
think also I needed that time it was
such a distraction to be working
full-time I needed that time every day
to truly be writing and I spent every
moment of that six months furthering my
career going to networking events
watching a different movie every day and
breaking it down and doing an outline so
I could understand the structure of it
all of those types of things and then
actually writing spending the time
writing so and reading so for me it
worked but I you know like I said I've
known people also who where it didn't
work and you know but you have to really
if you're gonna do something like that
you have to really make use of that time
you know it can't be one of these things
where you're gonna try to figure out
what you want to do creatively because I
think that you kind of just end up
treading water in a way you've got to
have a plan and you've got to execute
that plan fascinating I want to hear
more about the six months but just one
quick question before or two quick
questions actually and
is did you already know and forgive me
if this is too personal did you already
secure this loan so you knew or you knew
that you could go and get it no I know
that hey trust me when you're sixty
grand in debt let me just explain
something to you you get so many credit
card offers that will you know you can
pay twenty thousand here's an additional
twenty thousand they all want that
you're like the bomber ever oh right
because they know you carry debt so and
and I was making the minimum payments so
but again you're going further in debt
by by doing that but yet you're you're
sort of like the the golden child for
the credit card company so I had plenty
of offers I knew I could take out loans
additional loans and lines of credit on
my credit cards okay so which is it
wasn't if it was just which one yeah
okay gotcha
and then my other question was while you
were working at the YMCA were you also
writing on the side so you knew that
this you mean aside from going to film
school yeah I I thought I was going to
but I think at the level where you
become a senior program director I mean
you're working so many hours and you're
also I mean I had I had like I think
forty five people working under me at
that time and so when they don't show up
you have to cover and so you come home
and you're not in any place to really be
creative so I for me I found that I
wasn't during that time I had really
just put all the writing on the
backburner and that was it even on the
weekends I would get a few hours in but
it what that's not enough to to make a
career out of writing so during your two
weeks notice I assume were you planning
out like what your day was going to be
like what's the six months yeah yeah it
was I had a I definitely had a plan and
I knew um I knew that I wanted to spend
the time writing and I just needed to
figure out what I was most efficient at
I think and for me at that time it was
structure like I was always a really
good character writer and so I knew I
needed to learn structure better and so
that was one of the things I knew I was
gonna have to work on and so I bought
the books and I did all that kind of
stuff and so I was I was definitely
prepared during that time so that when I
could just I could jump off and begin my
six-month education since you know six
actually ticks by pretty quickly yeah
and I'm wondering what was day one like
what you got if I could even think about
what that was like I think um I think
there was a huge sense of relief in it
in that I was finally doing what I
probably should have been doing for the
last couple of years so you know and I
felt like I was gonna enjoy every moment
of this it may I may only get you know
six months of doing it so that's that's
basically what I did is I just really
enjoyed that this is gonna be the life
of a writer you know and probably that
was sort of bittersweet too because you
thought maybe this was the only six
months that she would ever this would
happen exactly but I but I wasn't
thinking that far ahead because I had a
lot of confidence that if I did this I
could make it happen so I don't think I
ever got caught up in that oh this might
be the only time I get to do this I
think I was looking at it more like this
is the beginning and I just have to
figure out how to make this last and how
to make the money back so that I could
continue to do it how did you know you
could trust yourself because I think
that's probably the number one thing is
knowing you could trust your time and
allocating the right resources I think
I've always been someone who trusts
myself in that um yeah I guess when it
comes to that kind of a thing you know
the only person that's gonna make
something happen as you and I feel like
just in general my perspective is you
have a lot of control over that so I
think for me you know I've gotten into
USC it was a very competitive program
graduated at the top of my class I had
won awards while I was there I knew I
was a good writer
I wasn't sure why I wasn't working like
I wasn't sure why I wasn't selling
scripts and so for me a lot of it was
like well it's not because you're not a
good writer it must be because you're
distracted you're not focused so you
just got to get that back and once you
do you'll be able to move forward and I
think that's where my head was at the
time yeah I think so many people it's
that big dilemma of like do I want to be
comfortable and have a job and
one that has a good title and that
friends and family are going to respect
and I respect myself for having or do I
want to unfortunately have life be a
little bit uncomfortable and that's so
were you prepared to be uncomfortable
whether it's cutting back on spending oh
yeah and I mean I think I still into
this day I think that I think I would
tell any writer that that you have to be
willing to sell your nice car to sell
your house and move back into an
apartment you have to love this job more
than you love anything you own because
it can go away like that and just
because you you have some success
doesn't mean you should ever get
comfortable with it because things
change the industry is always changing
you're changing you're getting older you
know there's new people coming in
there's so much influx all the time that
you really have to be in a place where
you're willing to give that up you have
to love it enough and if you don't love
it enough and you really just want money
there are a lot easier ways to go make
money than to be a screenwriter so that
would be my advice during the six months
were you doing this seven days a week
yeah Wow yeah but it didn't feel like it
didn't feel like work because I felt
like I was finally getting to do what I
really wanted to do and I woke up every
morning loving to write couldn't wait to
get back on the script and keep working
on it so it never felt like work to me
so lastly if someone said Christine I
know this is a huge risk and I know that
I shouldn't take a line of credit out
and I shouldn't or or even something use
up my savings whatever it is but I want
to risk it and I'm willing to face the
consequences what would you say are some
hard fast do's and don'ts and that's a
great question um I would say go into it
with a plan you can't waste a single
minute of that time so go into it with a
plan and tell other people your plan if
this is what you want to do first of all
if you tell many people that you're
gonna spend your life savings to make a
film or to pretend to be a screenwriter
for six months most people are going to
tell you not to do it most people told
not to do they thought it was crazy but
I think you have to ask yourself this
really hard questions like how much do
you trust yourself how much do you want
this and how much are you willing to
lose and give up you can always go back
and get a job at a why or State Farm or
wherever you're working and and in
general successful people tend to be
successful no matter what they do right
so you know if you were being promoted
at that job you can get another job
you'll probably be promoted at that job
as well
so I would say but go into it with a
plan and know what you want to get out
of it and have a way to measure that
success because a lot of times I think
writers we aren't very good at measuring
what's working for us and what isn't we
just sort of kind of willy-nilly go
today I feel like writing this and now
the scripts done and maybe I'll turn it
in and maybe I won't and maybe mine
rewrite it and you have to really kind
of look at your life like a business and
I think if you can manage it that way
you have a better you're better prepared
for seeing what's working and then and
continuing on that route or seeing
what's not working and abandoning that
that strategy so you have to look at it
more like a business that's that's a big
thing too so I'm just trying to figure
out the timeline okay so the six months
ends and then you don't go back to the
why he was like right well I wasn't like
suddenly rolling in money and getting
offers either and I did end up getting
at that time a lot of interest and I was
working writing so what I actually end
up doing was I was hired to rewrite
other people's scrubs so I didn't sell
my own but a production company hired me
to do some rewrites for a couple of
lifetime movies actually yeah couple of
lifetime movies they were doing lifetime
at the time and so I did that but it
wasn't enough to completely pay the
bills and I didn't know if there was
gonna be more because every time my
project ends you don't know when the
next one's coming so so during that time
I decided I needed to maintain what I
was doing during the day I need to be
able to take these meetings with
production companies and part of working
at the Y prevented me from doing that
because of my responsibilities there so
I basically needed a job that had less
responsibilities so during that time I
worked for a temp come
the that catered to the entertainment
stream and so I could pick which days I
wanted to work and I was also bartending
at night and so you know that was
something that wouldn't interfere yeah
and then I was wait waiting tables also
so kind of doing what a lot of people
who come to LA and do who want to be an
entertainment field do because it was
really hard to have the job where you
could make a decent salary because with
that comes the responsibility which
precluded me obviously from being able
to go and have the time I needed to
write when I was on these projects and
eventually I could just quit those jobs
and one at a time and got to the point
where I was making a living just writing
Wow so that would you say it was like a
few years out or yeah I would say
probably I would say that probably was
four or five years maybe before I could
get rid of all the other jobs but during
those four or five years I was rather
consistently working now on screenplays
and and building my body of work so you
could almost sense that it's going to be
around the corner
yeah just doesn't you know Wainwright
yeah interesting how are you dealing
with being tired from working so many
jobs cuz it sound
it's exhausting just getting ready for
one of those jobs but then you still
have to keep your mind intact to do
rewrites yeah I think it's um helps when
you're near 20s I did my parties
but yeah so in your 20s I mean you just
have a lot more energy sure okay but
also you know again the writing was what
I looked forward to so I would get up
and I'd go to the job because you have
to go to the job but then I would come
home and the writing was really
something that energized me and so I
never really looked at it like I needed
to be that I was just too tired to write
I just I don't think I've ever really
felt that because for me it's the thing
that I I just want to do all the time
like I'm always so much more comfortable
with a pen in my hand and a piece of
paper and just in case I have an idea or
something so for me it never felt like
that I was just curious where did were
one of your parents super discipline did
you watch because you just have this
amazing discipline both of them were you
know my parents
my dad was a very hard worker and I
think my sister and I both got our work
ethic from him he was a door-to-door
insurance salesman back when they had
those right and and he did very well and
but he was always working and my mom was
the very much pro education she has a
doctoral degree and so I think we were
just sort of this combination of you
know he never went to college but he
worked really hard and my mom was all
about you know she has multiple degrees
and so we kind of were a mix of both of
seeing both of those people in our lives
so and door to door it sounds like you
would have to be so self-care
and and he very much was not bad he's
very self-motivated right yeah cuz I
mean that would you talk about that
first knock on that door yeah yeah me
too I mean that's definitely not me
that's not my personality but for him
you know he's the type of person who I
mean people would say oh he could sell
ice to an Eskimo because he's just that
type of charismatic person and he loves
getting to know people and talking to
them and selling them and and he loves
selling things so that for him was a
great a great occupation but very
self-motivated because you do have to
get up every morning and you have to
decide where you're gonna go and who
you're gonna try to sell to and he had a
lot of control over that Wow interesting
you were doing rewrites for several
years when did you actually sell a first
script oh gosh you know I don't think I
sold a spec until years into my career
most of my early work was doing rewrites
and then talking to the producers and
saying you know you're you're basically
paying other people the bulk of the
money to do this original draft and then
I'm fixing it why don't you just hire me
to start so they were so then they said
yes we'll do that and so but those were
still work for hire project so they were
coming to me with the concepts and the
ideas or whatever and then I was just
writing them so it took a long time
before I actually sold a spec that I had
just written on my own and taken the
market so it sounds like the the
traditional way that you think of oh
you're gonna go pitch
and they're gonna like say yes and write
you a check you had already had inroads
and you're already doing work but you
were fixing other people's work and you
just kind of like created your own job
yeah basically it you know most people
when they think of screenwriting they
think of that they think of the pitch
and going into the room and pitching and
then something yes go write this for us
we love it and then you sell it and that
certainly exists it didn't for me that's
just there's a ton of work in rewriting
other people's stuff and most people
just don't know most writers don't know
how to rewrite like they they take it to
the level that they can either they
don't want to change it there's a lot of
writers who they really fall in love
with their stuff and they don't want to
make any changes and ultimately that
makes them get fired off a project and
then they bring on another writer who
will make the changes or they just have
taken it too you know as much as they're
able to take it and they want to bring
in the fresh sense so you know producers
will sometimes do that so that for me
was where most of my early work was
Braun I think that's great too because
you know the style of the person that
you're going to be writing for so I
think that's an excellent way do a lot
of people get in that way or is that
sort of an interesting way to kind of
create your own job I think it's I don't
know if a lot of people get in that way
I mean I do know other writers
especially in the TV world when you're
doing features for television a lot of
writers get in that way just being able
to write other people's rewrites you
know that's that's key if you can do
that you're pretty much gonna get hired
again and again because there are a lot
of people who know how to do that and
being able to let really listen to what
the producer runs and the more you do
that obviously the more you understand
budgets and what they want and sometimes
when you get cryptic notes you kind of
can navigate through those notes a
little bit better so yeah that's but
that is one way and a lot of people
don't think of I'm sure the writer that
does the rewrites is probably much
easier to deal with because they're not
as precious because in terms of it's not
their work it's not their baby
well that's being criticized that's very
true I think writers have to be very
careful about being precious because
even with my original stuff I have to
take a step back and make sure I'm not
being that way because I don't want to
suddenly be
the writer that they want to fire and
hire you know someone else but it's
difficult you know I mean especially the
more time you invest in a project I feel
like the more precious it becomes to you
it which is why I also I think it's
important to you know to finish projects
and some writers will work on something
for three or four years like one ones
grip and just you got to end it and you
got to move on to the next thing because
every time you move on to that next one
you become a better writer so get those
first seven under your belts and click
them off and then you know keep moving
and you know is you can always revisit
them but you've got to keep going
through it so even though the way you
sold your first script was through the
fact that you were already doing
rewrites and the people already knew
you're writing it and loved what you did
do you then go in cold and pitch and is
that a way that you've sold I am I've
never sold anything that way ever I've
never and I've done it I mean just like
every writer I've gone in the room and
pitched and yeah but typically those
projects don't pan out at least they
haven't for me most of the projects that
I get are usually because you've met a
director you've met an actor you've met
a producer you've talked about it for a
while yeah we want to work together you
come up with an idea is this the right
time eventually everything aligns and
you know they say hey we've got the
money you want to do the script let's
let's go for it now and that's how it
works
so we have a wonderful viewer named
Marcin and by the way hi Marcin and
thank you for all your comments how do I
ask a connection for example a
successful screenwriter to help me break
into the business literally how do i
phrase it and what do I ask them for
exactly Marcin that is a great question
first of all people who are successful
in the industry are very very busy and
if I wish you could see my desk because
I have literally probably 30 scripts on
my dust stacked up and they come from
there first of all there's the work
stuff that you have to read because
you're gonna either rewrite it or they
need you to read it for some reason or
other consulting jobs and then I have my
friends who I'm very close to who
are in my writers groups and I read
their stuff and they read mine and so we
sort of have this symbiotic relationship
and then there are the people I don't
know quite as well who send me scrubs to
get on that list is very difficult and
what a lot of new writers kind of don't
understand is that I don't have a lot of
free time and so you know if I'm gonna
spend any time at all you know having a
life I can't say yes to everyone who
asked me to read their script because
literally I probably get a request a day
to read someone's row so that's a very
tough thing so first of all let me just
say this don't get your feelings hurt if
someone says no they can't read it for
you or they can't help you because they
just can't and it's just I just want to
make that really clear it doesn't mean
that they're awful people or they don't
care about you or they don't want you to
be successful and I think sometimes
people take that wrong and the best way
to get people to read your script is to
network go to and there are so many ways
you can do it join writers groups number
one that's the biggest thing have other
people at your level reading your script
giving you notes and then as you get
better they get better and then everyone
sort of can you sort of develop this
network of people that you can go to so
that you're not just cold calling asking
someone hey will you we read this
networking with people so that you sort
of do a favor for them and now they owe
you a favor so an example that I
sometimes give is go volunteer at a film
festival you know it's it costs you
nothing you get to go you get to meet
everybody you get to meet all the
filmmakers that are there you get to
meet the people who are running it they
owe you a favor get to know them
volunteer to be on someone's set go PA
for two weeks someone who comes in pas
for free for me for two weeks
I'm much more likely to say yes they're
gonna get on that pile versus someone I
don't know right so start building the
network first before you want to just
hand off a script because otherwise even
if they say yes a lot of times it takes
some months and months to read it and
then you're just kind of waiting and you
shouldn't be waiting you should be
moving on always be moving on to your
next project so that's my advice
yeah and in in a similar question as
Marcin has I knew someone who was upset
that a friend of hers did not help her
and was higher up on the sort of writing
food chain and was very upset about that
and I don't know how I feel about that
I've never asked anybody like that but
it would be a tricky situation and this
person was offended that the other
person didn't help them and I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are on that
because then there's a relationship at
stake yeah I think I think you have to
be careful about that because just
because someone's honest a higher up on
the food chain although I really don't
like that they're just further along on
their journey than you are and the thing
is is that that doesn't necessarily mean
they have the right contacts to help you
either and a lot of people don't really
understand that they think oh you must
be so well-connected or because I've
sold a lot like for lifetime they think
oh well you must know if I give you this
script you can take it to lifetime for
me
I dunno what lifetime is looking for
because I work with them a lot a lot of
times that script isn't what they're
looking for so you know even if it was a
great script I know it's not what
they're looking for I can't pass that on
for you so there's a lot of pieces of
information you just don't know it's
very easy to get resentful I think in
this because you work really hard every
writer does and sometimes it takes a
really long time for things to pan out
and so you're looking for any means you
can and anyone that will just give you
that leg up you know and and and I've
been there and I get it but you have to
be very careful because I think that
those things can weigh on you a lot and
when you start getting too reliant on
other people doing things for you like
oh well I tried to give it to her but
she wouldn't pass it on and then so that
was a setback and then I tried to get my
friend to do this because he knows an
agent but he wouldn't look at it and
that was I think that you're doing
yourself a disservice so if you're
constantly looking for the next way for
you to develop the relationship with the
people you need to
meeting instead of relying on other
people you're just gonna be helping
yourself down the road and those
relationships build over years and at
the end of that now you're the person
that people are coming to interesting
okay yeah thank you so I think aside
from writing all these scripts that you
do and rewrites but you also do like
speaking engagements and you go to I do
um
I speak a lot of conferences actually
and I do a lot of workshops which are a
lot of fun I love teaching and so and
then I also do consulting when people
hire me to read their scribes so I do
that too which is also great because
it's also another form of teaching when
I do consulting usually they obviously
give me a feature that I'm giving notes
on but it's really not about notes for
that particular script it's about
teaching them how to become better
writers and so that's a lot of fun for
me too and so they can go to your
website which will have underneath a
video and yeah the information is there
yeah okay great let's say I'm a
hypothetical person attending one of
these conferences and then I'm one of
the people waiting in line to talk to
you and you know just say hey really
enjoy the information I was wondering
dot dot dot and that is how can I become
a working writer so I don't have to work
a part-time job I just want to go right
into it I think that everybody's journey
is so different in this business you
know if you want to become a doctor you
go to med school you do your residency
and you become a doctor and you know you
go work at a hospital that's not the way
it works in the film industry the key to
success in the film industry is being
open to opportunities and being able to
see them when they come everybody has
sort of this type A personality plan
right where we go okay so I want this by
this date and then I'm gonna try to do
this and and we think of that as being
ambitious right that we have a plan
we're working toward something and
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that but if you get too obsessed with
that so much so that you don't see
opportunities that come to you that may
not fall in that plan you can miss out
on a lot of opportunities and so like I
tell this story
I've told it before when I was in film
school a friend of mine does Amba movies
and there's only five girls in my class
and so I was always a zombie and one of
his movies because he had no one else to
choose from and I'm years later fast
forward we were graduated and he's a
real producer and he calls me up he's
like hey Christine I'm doing a real
zombie movie do you want to come down
and be a zombie just for old times sake
and I was like sure I'll come down for
one day and so I go down and I'm sitting
there and I'm in full zombie makeup like
my hair is he's out I'm green and I'm
sitting there with the background and if
you've ever been on a film set you know
that you know background is pretty
boring you're sitting around most the
time and but it's fun and it's a great
day off and as I'm sitting there I meet
this guy also a zombie who had just
arrived from from Boston and he had
gotten a part on an HBO series called
Carnivale this is actually several years
ago and we start talking and he tells me
that he has the rights to this off
Broadway play and he's looking for
someone to adapt it so at the end of the
day he was a cool guy really nice I tell
him well you know if you need someone to
adapt that into a screenplay for you let
me know and then the very next day the
director calls me it was like I heard
you're adapting our off-broadway play
and I was like oh yeah I did commit to
that yesterday but sure so well let's
meet and talk about it so I go to meet
with him and the director and this guy
and I realized when I get to the coffee
shop we're gonna meet I don't know what
they look like because we were all
dressed as zombies and so I have no clue
what they even look like so we finally
find each other and we end up doing a
short and that short premiere at the LA
Latino Film Festival and that was great
it was a great experience I got to walk
the red carpet wonderful I just did it
to be nice right after just doing
something to be nice for my friend from
college a year later I get a call from
them and they're like you know what
Christine and we have some good news
based on the short that we did
we've got financing to make the feature
do you want to write the screenplay for
$25,000
and I mean yeah of course no I'm gonna
say no to 25 gram
so especially when I was still in debt
and all and this was during that that
period of five years where you know I
was just doing things to be on film sets
and to network and so yeah I did that
and again that was an opportunity very
still very proud of that film that film
became Hotel California
starring Tatiana Ali had a great cast it
premiered the following year so two
years later as a feature at the LA
Latino Film Festival and did very well
so again you have to be open to
opportunities I never went in to playing
a zombie thinking I'm gonna meet
somebody who's going to have me write a
short that we're gonna then turn into a
future it doesn't work out that way just
make yourself available and try to meet
the right people and create situations
where people owe you favors and they
want to work with you again and when you
can do that then those opportunities
will start to come but you've got to be
able to recognize them when they happen
that's a great story I feel like we're
in this sort of like hacking bubble
where everybody's got it wants to try to
like make this quicker and make that
quicker and if I follow this person on
social media they might they might just
put me in the project which it all
happens I know that it does but I feel
like we were in this new era of
everything's got to be quicker and it
sounds like you although I'm sure you
wanted certain things to go faster you
did things a little bit of a different
way but I think a lot of it was I never
went into all of that thinking that
there was gonna be some payoff
I just loved being on film sets I loved
meeting other filmmakers I loved taking
an off-broadway play and adapting I'd
never done that before and so for me it
was more about the love of doing those
things rather than the payoff of somehow
I can I can turn this into a moneymaker
for me or somehow I can make this turn
this into a rung in my career it was
never ever like that so you know the
Deepak Chopra says you know we make
every decision based on love or fear
right so
all of those decisions when I look back
now I know we're based on the love of
writing and the love of becoming a
screenwriter not the fear of am I
wasting my time helping this person when
I should be helping that person because
they're gonna pay me quicker they're
gonna get me into their movie or they're
gonna do this it was never like that for
me right I like this your intention was
different it wasn't about what were you
gonna get right and when you're not
looking at what the pay when you're not
trying to see what the payoff is down
the line there's no there's a
disappointment in it when the payoff
doesn't come because you're open to
whatever that's gonna lead you to next
and so your since you're quoting Deepak
Chopra I'm gonna quote Louise hey since
we're going there and her thing that I
love that she would say was well that's
not a million dollars and people stop on
it and walk away from it because again
we're so we're looking for you know I
mean I'm sure everybody would love to
walk the red carpet but it took these
little steps it took you going to the
set it took you talking to this guy it
you know it forming a relationship a
business relationship and then then that
happen but people just see that result
of oh she's on the right carpet a that I
want to be there exactly and they don't
really know what it takes to get there
and and that's why again you have to be
so careful about letting yourself become
resentful like looking at other people
and where they are and saying why can't
I get there why can I get there that
energy is not well spent
so focus on why are you writing if your
goal and just honestly be honest with
yourself if your goal is to make money
if your goal is to be famous if your
goal is to be recognizable and have a
name then this may not be the career for
you because there there are easier ways
to get those things than by being a
screenwriter
so I think if you just can say I love
writing I want to see what today brings
and enjoy every moment that you get to
be on set you get to be talking to
directors whatever you're doing you know
these writing conferences are a great
example when you go to these writing
conferences people are there because
they just love to write they're just
soaking it in
and it's such a creative inspiring
environment spend your time doing those
things right and take every piece of
information that you can and and learn
and become better at what you do because
the gratification that you've got from
becoming really good and writing
something and saying wow this is pretty
amazing that I mean nothing compares to
that not walking a red carpet not seeing
your name on television nothing compares
to that feeling as a writer who's had so
many screenplays produced what have you
learned about what studios are looking
for um you know it's always changing
number one I don't work a lot with
studios I work a lot with networks
because most of what I do is for
television so um you know it depends I
think they're looking for something that
fits their model when you go to sell a
script you're either selling to a
producer or to a network or studio those
basically that's it so if you're working
with a producer they have budget
constraints they have location
constraints they typically have a
business model where they make so many
films a year at a certain budget level
and then they know who they're gonna
sell them to it's a business so you have
to be very hyper aware of what those
constraints are for them and if you are
and you can write to those constraints
then you have a much better chance of
selling your your script
so understanding budgets understanding
production those types of things are
really important for screenwriters and a
lot of times that's the piece that they
kind of leave out the most writers want
to sit behind a computer and write and
they don't really like to get out there
and so they don't like to get out there
and learn about production and stuff but
the more I learned about production the
more I became a producer the better
writer
I also became because I understood what
could be done at certain budget levels
and I understood the tricks of shooting
and and how to make that
that'll work and then ultimately that's
what kind of combined which helped me
become a director then also so then know
the studio or the network that you kind
of want to write for absolutely pay
attention to what they
put out I have so many people tell me oh
this is a great script for hallmark or
this is a great script for a lifetime
and I read it I'm like this is not at
all what hallmark wants or what lifetime
wants or so they're not paying attention
you know to what is being put out it
because they think that theirs is gonna
fit that model and it really doesn't so
you have to be very open-minded and and
self-critical before you decide that
it's right for a network or a studio
because it may not be so I think you
said earlier that most of the
screenplays that you've sold have been
through prior working relationships
where you knew the person but when you
did go and pitch because it sounds like
you you have done that when someone said
no what did that no mean to you um it
meant that the project wasn't right for
them at that time you know I I think you
have to be you have to have a lot of
confidence in your writing first of all
to get to that level where you're able
to pitch and they're willing to take a
pitch from you you're probably at a
level where you know you're a pretty
good writer so you can't let that
discourage you I mean there are projects
that we've pitched all over town that I
still love and I still think are great
projects and no one's bought them and so
it's just it wasn't the right time for
that you can kind of obsess over that if
you want but the best thing to do is you
just keep moving on go to your next one
go to your next one you can always come
back and revisit something later and a
lot of times when you do revisit it you
start to see things about it that you
didn't see before like oh I should have
done this differently or knowing what I
know now I would do this because you're
just more informed than you were before
so that's to me you just don't let it
discourage you that's the biggest take
away from that did you always have that
approach to it or was the first time you
know sort of I always had that approach
I I think my attitude was always and I
think I've gotten softer as I've gotten
older but I think when I was younger my
attitude was always like well you know
if they don't like it forget them you
know I'm moving on to the next person
like if they don't get it
someone else will so but I think that is
the right
to to have and now I think you know I
think that you can you can internalize a
lot of things on the writer and I think
writers tend to we're always looking for
like oh what did I do wrong what could I
do better well you know why isn't this
working for me and I think that if you
just stay true to what you believe in
eventually you're gonna find that
audience that's gonna connect to that
and that producer and maybe it's just
the timing maybe you haven't met them
yet but again it goes to why networking
is so important expanding that group of
people and networking and finding the
right people that you want to work with
that who creatively aligned with you is
really really important yeah and the
interesting thing is to so many things
changed behind the scenes whatever part
of the industry that you're in and
you'll never know why
and you won't know is it me is it what
what was it did I say the wrong thing
whatever it's how actors this all the
time
from a director standpoint when we do
auditions and they you know they come
into the room and they have five minutes
to do their read we know the moment they
walk in if it's a no and Wow
I tell actors all the time like don't
obsess over what you should have said
differently or how you should have
delivered a line it's not even about
that they either we either connected you
to that character or we didn't period
and it's sort of the same with writing
you know you're gonna find people who
you just at one point you're gonna be
the one this is the project someone
loves this project it's what they want
to do and they get it but there's gonna
be lots of people who don't you know
that's why there's lots of stuff on
television that's why there's lots of
movies playing at any given time you
know it's there's not one thing for
everybody so don't take no for an answer
just keep moving like that so when you
take on a TV writing project how much
information does the network give you
ahead of time it depends so sometimes
they'll come to me
well it'll be either the network or a
producer so they can come from either
but sometimes it'll just be a title so
for example you know we have for
lifetime we've done a franchise of
different movies like we've done the at
17 series so we've got several titles
that are have at 17 or the perfect or
the online
so they'll come back to the producer
usually and say we want to do another
installment of the app 17 series and so
how about this title and then we kind of
get together and I come up with some
ideas and run and past the producer I
mean then we send them to the network
and we see what they say and if they
like him then we develop them so it can
be that way it can come from the other
way when I did the bride he bought
online which I wrote and then directed
for a lifetime it was actually I had
written that as a horror movie and was
gonna direct it and crowdfund and direct
that as a low-budget horror and then
ended up pitching it because they had
said well we're looking for some teenage
really for a thriller with teenagers and
so I thought well this one easily adapts
so I'll have to do is sort of make it
less horror II and more thriller II and
I did that and so you know it can come
back direction too so that one came from
me and then they liked that so it's just
understanding those needs that they have
and fulfilling and sometimes they come
to you and sometimes you come to them
that it's always a very collaborative
relationship but by the time it gets
made it's gone through a lot of people's
hands and ideas and fascinating so let's
suppose it's one of these where someone
throws the title at you so they say you
know what let's meet in two weeks what's
your process going to be like for those
two weeks to come up with I mean I'm not
even sure are they even giving you sort
of a synopsis of who this character is
or no they're just tight sometimes they
do sometimes they don't a lot of times
they'll just say you know we want it
needs to be a female lead this age we're
looking for a thriller it has to be
contained it has to be the times that's
held the budget level so because that
makes a big difference in you know how
many locations you have and that kind of
thing so then you just come up with some
ideas that can fit and and then they
they're spark to those ideas or they
don't and a lot of times it's like well
I like that idea but we're doing
something kind of similar what if she
did this instead and and so that's how
it comes about so those conversations
end up becoming the basis for whatever
you're going to write so then in those
two weeks I mean are you do you have
sort of almost come
of of main characters in your head like
I can see this happening to this person
or I mean I'm just wondering that sounds
fascinating no not really I think I just
kind of come up with those I start
thinking about it
at the spur of the moment so a lot of
times I'll get inspiration like I'll
watch a few movies and see what they've
done lately and and then I'll think well
you know this is sort of an interesting
what they did this was unique what if we
did something like this or I have never
seen a character who is agoraphobic so
let's give her that and like that'll
kind of bring an interesting element to
it so those types of things and I think
also like I just read a lot I'm always
looking for interesting articles about
crime and stuff like that because truth
is stranger than fiction a lot of times
so you can find out interesting things
that you don't even know exists like
diseases and psychoses and the way
people get away with something for so
long and so taking those elements and
sort of just collecting those and having
them always ready I think are kind of
helps a lot too interesting so you're
always sort of just an avid reader of
various things whether it's like a
police crime blotter in that and
whatever in the local and then you just
kind of file it away yeah I'm
interesting yeah and when I find
something really interesting sometimes
it'll be interesting enough that I'll
say you know we should maybe do this
story but usually by the time you've
pitched it ten other people have pitched
that if it's if it's already made
headlines ten of the people already
pitch that story to them so it's just
keeping that kind of stuff in mind so
that when you're writing you go oh this
actually this would be really
interesting and I haven't seen it before
does the network require that you submit
an outline before you start writing
sometimes it depends on the exec that
you're working with and it depends on
the producer sometimes the producer will
require it sometimes it's just we go
from one paragraph to one page sometimes
we go from one paragraph to a script it
whatever they want whatever makes them
feel comfortable in their process is
what I deliver to them what's the
typical show that you're writing for the
length of time that it takes me to write
it oh oh or that what would be the
typical air time oh so for most
television it's 83 to 86
minutes for a feature okay so then what
does that translate into in terms of it
just pens on the producer in terms of
pages so you know though the sort of the
standard is one page equals one minute
of screen time that's sort of a loose
guide so I have a producer I work with
who won't shoot anything under 116 pages
because he likes to have a lot of
footage to cut down to help with the
pacing
I have other producers I work with who
they don't want anything over a hundred
pages so it depends on their prop again
their production process so yeah
interesting yeah so I'm really getting
the sense that it's about flexibility it
is about yes being flexible is is
definitely a help and and giving them
what again giving them what they want so
many when I ask producers why do you
fire writers I ask every producer I've
worked with why do you fire writers and
they will always say because they don't
give me what I asked them to give me so
it's either notes they've given and then
the writer comes back and they haven't
done that with the notes because they
thought they knew better or they just
didn't know how or they asked for a
certain page count and it wasn't that
page count to me those are the wrong
reasons to get fired off of a project
those are things you can control so if
you're just paying attention and asking
them what they want
and they want to tell you what they want
so I ask you know what do you want your
page lengths to be here where do you
want your ACK lengths to be and then
that's what I give on wow that's
interesting
so what's the timeframe that you're
usually given once you've once they've
given you the title you've met with them
you've come up with some ideas what time
frame are you working with it depends
typically I get four weeks for a first
draft and then two weeks for every
subsequent draft which is it's pretty
quick actually it's not that difficult
if you're only working on one project at
a time but a lot of times you you know
if you're a working writer you're
working on multiple projects because it
takes so long before one of them
suddenly comes back and says okay we're
we're greenlit we can actually move
forward you don't know when that's going
to happen
so you know you've got all these sort of
irons in the fire and then eventually
one will come back and sometimes to come
back which is great but now you have to
balance how you're gonna you know
deliver both of those scripts so that's
suppose let's just have it be one
because I'm really curious how you spend
your time and how you how you organize
it so if you have four weeks to write a
first draft for one what's your work
schedule going to be like so my process
is probably a little different than most
people I I write fifteen pages a day so
basically I figure out when it's due and
I back out 15 pages per day and I take
into consideration if I've got something
going on in the afternoon like today is
not a 15 page day because I'm I'm with
you guys thank you but I and then I work
until those 15 pages are done so if I'm
done at 3 o'clock because I had a great
writing day and it went really smoothly
fantastic if it takes me till 9 o'clock
it takes me till 9 o'clock and then
that's when I end my day
it helps too it helps me to do that
because I keep on track and I also don't
get caught up in my own oh my gosh I'm
loving this I just want to keep going
because that can happen too when you're
really on a roll writing you'll I mean
I've had that happen where you just
don't eat you just keep working through
the night and you're just so excited
about what you're writing that's fine
but you can't make a living living that
way right you have I have relationships
and I have people and dinner to make and
things like that and so I stopped when I
this is my way of doing it I stopped at
15 pages and that's it and pick back up
tomorrow and start again were you always
that precise with it I mean that's
faster yeah it's kind of it feels very I
know that seems very technical right for
something that's so creative but again
like I said before you have to look at
this like a business right so you have
to plan and organize and figure out
what's giving you the best results and
for me this gave me the best results
because I know at page 11 I only have a
few more pages to do and I can be done
and so you know and at the beginning of
every day I start out and I go okay
that's enough it's a big enough chunk
that I'm not forcing myself to go back
and reread that's a deadly thing that
writers do is they go back and they
rewrite themselves over know
over so forces you to keep moving
through and then you do your rewrite at
the end so once once those 110 pages or
whatever are done that's when you that's
when I go back and I build in usually a
couple days off because you need that
time away from it
to kind of forget about it a little bit
and then when I come back and I reread
it I give myself two or three days to do
the rewrite and it's just basically
cleaning everything up or changing at
breaks or you know if I've come up with
an idea in between that time to add then
I'll do that that's great because I mean
really in a sense you want to think that
you're your own boss but really the
network is your boss so you're working
for them but you've also got to monitor
yourself so that sounds like a great way
to keep yourself on track so you're not
doing two pages a day but you're not
burning yourself out right and I think
also you can get obsessed with is the
writing good is it not good do I like
this do I not like it when you have to
get those 15 pages done eventually you
have to say screw it I've got to move on
and it forces you to move on which i
think is good for the process because
nothing really good comes from sitting
there obsessing over the same scene so
it is what it is I moved on I can come
back to it and giving yourself
permission to do that I think is very
healthy and I think it's actually good
for the process and the product so now
let's suppose you have three projects
going are you still doing 15 pages it
depends so yes so 15 pages on something
I don't you know some writers will say
I'm going to do 7 pages on this project
in the morning and then 7 pages I don't
do that I say okay this is my I'm doing
15 pages today on this and I'm taking
three days off to work on the next
project and then I come back to it so
that's kind of how I organize it I have
a hard time splitting it up and trying
to work on different multiple projects
than in the same day especially at 15
pages I think if you were doing fewer
maybe but 15 is pretty ambitious yeah
that would sound difficult if the
stories are so different or you know you
just want to keep the character and all
that separate and you have to split it
up and one day because your mind is good
it's worse when they're actually similar
like if they're both projects for the
same network because or they're both
thrillers because then that's when it
gets confusing it's actually better when
doing like a romantic comedy and then
also working on a thriller because
they're so different you don't you don't
mix those characters up at all
it's that obsessing though it truly is
I've seen so many writers who will sit
there and they will go over the same
thing over and over and it's just not
productive at all right so you're really
okay we we can talk I wanted to talk
about once the draft is because that's I
think we've heard from a few writers
that some of them do like three to five
pages a day so forgive me because I'm
not in that space writing scripts but
how are you able to do 15 a day I mean
that's fact I think I think a lot of
well first of all I think over time you
just get better right so you know it's
not 10,000 hours once you put that in
and you become the expert in whatever
you're doing you know you can recognize
when things aren't working you recognize
when they are working for me to do the
15 pages you can't waste time at all on
obsessing over if you like the scene or
you like this line of dialogue it's it
is this is it it's on the page you move
on and then everything's about coming
back and refining it later but getting
it out is a much more productive use of
time then getting stuck and sort of that
turmoil of not knowing if this is good
or if you want to go this direction or
whatever I have to make his decision and
and move forward and when you do that
you tend to get a draft done faster
which gives you more time to go back and
kind of remould that draft a lot of
writers also turn in their first drafts
and I think it's really important to
never show anyone the first draft to
always go back at least once and clean
things up because it just makes such a
difference
well that was yeah it was curious what
happens after the four weeks you haven't
read it let's suppose you have a hundred
and ten pages or so give or take I'm
assuming then you're coming through it
well the 110 would be in three weeks so
that I would give myself that last week
take a couple days off right so at 15
pages a day
what is that for a hundred page I mean
you only really need 10 days right to
write the initial draft and then the
rest of that is going back up and
cleaning it up and
moving your app brakes and tweaking
dialogue and that kind of stuff
oh and so you then you throw in the
three days to let it breathe for a
little bit so you give it some space and
then you come back again BAM it's four
weeks and then you have a meeting with
someone that's at how it works yeah okay
interesting so four weeks you're showing
it to this person and what does that
process like um so I send it in and it
depends on usually if it's a very first
draft the producer is gonna read it
first they need to make sure that
they're on board and you obviously when
you go to the studio or the network then
you go as a team with the producer so
they are happy with the draft so they
usually give you a set of notes first I
implement those notes and then once
they're happy then it goes to the
network or the studio and we get their
notes back so by the time they read it
we already know that the producers
approved it for budget and they like it
and so you've kind of got that person in
your corner too if there is something to
fight for like if there's a I guess if
they don't agree with I don't know
whatever creative decision you've made
the producer is already on board and
understanding why you did that and
they're sort of on board with you so it
makes it a more productive meeting also
to have that then just like a bunch of
different people giving random different
notes that's those are the worst and
I've had that experience too but it's
not it's not the best way to do it you
know it's better to kind of like go
through the process correctly because
then then the drafts get better and
better so I wonder if we can even go in
closer to a day of doing 15 pages what
time do you start what is that what is
it like doing those pages I usually I
get up early so I usually get up around
6:00 and I start writing right away and
yeah I mean it's I take a break for
lunch when I get hungry and otherwise I
mean I'm really just focused on getting
those pages done and that's it I don't
know I don't know how to tell you any
different yeah since the day and you
know it's a lot of sitting in front of a
computer right and so you it's 6:00 a.m.
you're ready like I get more done in the
first two hours of my day than probably
the last five hours of my day so
you know whatever I'm doing if I'm at
the gym it's a better workout in the
morning if I'm here working it's you
know I'm getting a more productive I'm
getting more written so I try to take
advantage of those hours I happen to be
a morning person right you know I get
that and and I know we've talked to
other people I think you have less
distractions then too whether it's just
you know just knowing you're up before a
lot of other people or whatever they're
controlling distractions I mean you can
check email every 10 minutes if you want
or check Facebook every 10 minutes if
you want but you have to you have to
force yourself not to do that because
that really interrupts your ability to
focus and you're forcing yourself not to
go back and reread be right because then
you're gonna be stuck on exactly
interesting now was that always the way
for you did you go back and reread stuff
and did you learn I think I think I
developed that over needing to be able
to finish these projects more quickly
and find a more efficient way to do it
because I remember when when I was in
college and writing I would do this
thing where you know I would get
obsessed with the writer's block oh I
can't get through the scene this is
holding me up and and it's just it's
just a waste and that's fine when you're
writing as a hobby it's not really fine
then either but you know at least you
can manage it when you're when you have
deadlines and you know you're getting
paid and people are expecting scripts
and there's a crew waiting on you to do
this so they can shoot it yeah you don't
have that luxury anymore so you just
find the most efficient way are a lot of
these productions taken to Canada to
shoot the film quite a few are but
there's actually still quite a few that
are shot in LA and and a lot of places
we've you know Georgia there's a lot of
stuff is shot now in Georgia New York
even New Mexico so they're expanding a
little bit a lot of it has to do with
the the coming and going of tax credits
and the availability of cruise so as
these little pods sort of develop you
know like for example then Coover was
really hot it's still very hot when
Vancouver was sort of on the come-up
there weren't very many cruise so
everyone take their films to Vancouver
but there's nowhere to work on them so
then you know so them they now they have
film schools and they're developing that
more so now more films in and so that's
always in flux and everyone's trying to
do that do you ever go on set I did yes
oh you do okay and so what's it like to
be on set
first of all how long is the production
usually um it depends so a lot of these
TV movies shoot for about 12 to 14 days
so the time on set is actually very
short a lot of time I mean some of them
in Canada we were shooting six-day weeks
usually their five-day weeks yeah so
you're not there very long when I go to
onset I'm usually there for a week for
prep and then the two weeks and then if
I'm not directing I'm just writing
there's no reason to be there after it
wraps if I'm directing then obviously
I'm there for a little bit or producing
them there after it wraps but otherwise
I come home so as a writer on set
what are you sort of just and forgive me
just but like seen but not heard and
then if they have something they need
worked on then you're there or how is
that I have actually been really lucky
because the producers who have asked me
to come on set they want me to be there
working so I'm meeting with the actors
the actors are going over their lines a
lot of times they'll have things they
want to to change or whatever so I'm
doing that as they're going on the tech
Scouts I go with them and I'm rewriting
based on what how the director wants to
shoot something so I'm rewriting the
scene so that it matches what they've
discussed they want that kind of thing
so if you're really part of the process
where as it seems like is that more film
then where the writer is sort of just
like great we have your thing we'll call
you if we need you yeah I mean there's
those also you know and there are
certainly producers that you know you
sell the script and you don't even know
it's shooting right and then it suddenly
comes down like oh my movie came out and
no one told me so there's there's
obviously that too
and that's typically how it is I've just
been with producers who they like having
the writer on set to make those changes
quickly so yeah but it's both ways and
neither way is right or wrong you know
they was kind of talked about how the
writer isn't really no one cares about
the writer and it's like that goodby and
you don't even get invited to like to
premiere anything but but you are sort
of out of the process at that point you
know you're so much a part of the
beginning of the process and then you
really hand it off and they take over
and you should be moving on to your next
thing I haven't watched television in a
few years just because we've been busy
doing film courage and you know we watch
a lot of Netflix things like that but I
used to watch a lot of Lifetime movies
and I'm just wondering has the character
type evolved absolutely okay curious
yeah because what the one I was watching
it it was probably early 2000s maybe mid
tooth and so it was more I'm thinking of
a Connie sellecca as like you know the
mom that's fighting for her kids or
something which is great but I'm just
wondering how has it become a little
edgier I think it has its you know it's
interesting because like anything
television is always reacting to what's
going on in society right so and and
they're always sort of bound by ratings
because that's the game right if you
have a network it's all about getting
the highest rating so so networks are
always evolving and you know when I when
I remember a lifetime when I was a kid
and my mom used to watch it it was like
a lot of like women getting beat up and
then like fighting back finally you know
and so we've kind of gone through all of
that and now it's it's very much about
female protagonists but it's also about
evil women and and it's there's family
components to it but there's also a lot
about women who are in their career so
it's it's really kind of expanded to to
I guess reflect women in society and
what they want to see so yeah it's it
and it changes all the time we get new
mandates all the time like okay we're
not doing those types of movies anymore
we want to focus more on these types of
movies and so you know and then they try
it out and either they work or they
don't and so again it's just always
evolving and the theme of the secret in
terms and I'm not talking about the book
the secret but like that they're like
hidden things that are uncovered it
sounds like that's a huge part it is and
for especially for a lifetime like they
really like the everyday woman so a lot
of times it's you know a story about a
woman who witnessed a crime you know
something that could happen to you that
you wouldn't expect and now suddenly
you're thrown into this situation and
you're having to deal with just the
tools that you have as a
an everyday person to try to get out of
this extraordinary situation and then
the whole online component which when I
was watching it was just kind of coming
into the sort of cycle and a lot of that
I mean so much of it now is reflective
of all the social media stuff and
cybercrime and and everything that goes
on online online dating and so it's it's
constantly holding up a mirror to what
we're doing and it's creating a lot of
fears I mean I have to it's kind of
funny in this sense that you know if you
just watched some of these networks you
would think like online dating is the
most unsafe thing on the planet to do
right because everybody's a crazy but
you know that's what makes them fun too
right
right because it's always sort of like
the perfect guy or a perfect girl or
whatever and I think those are some of
the know and you don't expect that but
then there's something a little bit off
but we get off on that like it's it's
kind of interesting you know so exact a
heightened version of what we kind of
see anyway is that and there's an online
component to it you know we're never a
movie premieres there's a whole like we
watch the Twitter feeds you know people
watching and tweeting at the same time
with people they don't even know you
know watching the same movie and either
making fun of it or you know oh my god I
can't believe she actually did that or
oh I knew it was him you know that kind
of stuff and so that they've really
embraced that too because that's the
direction we've all moved fastening so
if you're doing sort of instead of like
watching a football game people are
tweeting about it or a political debate
they're watching a Lifetime movie and so
you're looking at that information to
seeing like why people reacted a certain
way I find it fascinating as the writer
to see where people are surprised and if
we were able to misdirect and if it
worked and that kind of thing so I like
watching that I mean the the network's
watch it for other reasons because they
they have a social media platform and
you know obviously it helps their
ratings and stuff so but for me um I
just like to see what people are
guessing and what they're not guessing
and if if we've you know duped them into
believing this person's the bad guy when
it's really that guy and for me as fun
so I know we're talking about writing be
very practical
business life but it sounds like you
really do have to be your own sort of
you know middle manager or boss the
stress and sort of unromantic notion of
deadlines
how romantic a phrase you know deadlines
are the things that may that separate
someone who writes for a hobby from
someone who writes for a living and
those are two very different things so
there is a stress obviously
to deadlines but there's also a relief
to deadlines in that once you're done
with this project it's done once it
shoots you're you're off of it otherwise
you know when it's your hobby it's your
sort of this this project that you can
work on forever sometimes people do work
on them forever so you know knowing that
you're gonna get to the finish line and
then move on to the next thing helps
keep you looking forward and I actually
really enjoy that you know I one of the
things I didn't like about the YMCA was
dealing with the same issues over and
over the same personnel issues you know
the same two people that you're
counseling three months ago are back in
your office and we're talking about this
again the same budgets every quarter
you're putting them together again it
got really boring I for me I love going
full force into one project and then now
I'm done I can forget about it and I'm
full forced into the next thing so
that's the beauty of deadlines right so
you're not because I know I think you'd
mentioned about like you didn't totally
want a day job and I I get that because
it is a lot of that same whatever the
dynamic is but then there's new problems
with being on your own because there's
like this freefall sort of that could
happen or if you keep yourself on track
which it sounds like you are excellent
at yeah I try to be yeah you know
absolutely it sounds like it I mean it's
that's that's a skill in itself though
yeah I think that's but that is a part
you really have to develop and you have
to again I always tell writers this
you've got to view this you know because
everyone sees writing as their dream job
right and they have this fantasy that
they get up in the morning and they're
still in their pajamas and they're
petting their cats and they're writing
for two hours and it's this wonderful
you know
existence and it can be whatever you
want it to be right you're obviously in
control of it but you have to approach
it like a business you're you're doing
it not just because you love it anymore
but also to make money there's a whole
other component and if you can balance
them right you can have both you can
still love it and you can still make
money but the money part is a big part
of it you know because we all have bills
to pay so if that's not for you then
keep it a hobby you know and enjoy the
process of writing two pages a day if
that's what you like to do that luxury
goes as soon as it becomes a profession
what did you do to get better as a
writer from 10 years ago to now what do
you think it's been whether it's just
the 10,000 hours we talked about it's a
lot of it is the 10,000 I mean I'm a big
believer in that once you put in your
10,000 hours you're at a place where you
just have the confidence and you know
what you're doing and so the obstacles
that you encounter you just know how to
tackle them and so that's very different
then I think then I was 10 years ago
before I had done that but I think also
just being able to recognize your
deficiencies and for me you know when I
read a great script and I go oh my gosh
you know this is a great script
I get really excited about it what are
they doing that I'm not doing like what
can I learn from what this writer did
and so I think just constantly learning
you know and constantly reading and
constantly researching and having that
in the back of your mind all the time
that you want to get better you'll just
gravitate towards things that make you
better instead of finding that
comfortable place where you know you
know you're good at writing this so I'm
just gonna write this over and over I
think forcing yourself to stretch and
because once you do that again it's it's
a great feeling you know when you've
written something good and you've done
something you haven't done before you
then you have something that you feel
really proud of I'm wondering what
scripts those are if do you have one off
the top of your head that you looked at
it was like wow I wish had written that
or I want to do something it happens all
the time I got
can't think of like a specific one
that's just come out but I was just
speaking on a panel and it was we were
reading the first five pages of a bunch
of people's scripts and then we were
critiquing them and we didn't know the
whole panel was and we didn't know whose
was whose and there was one that I
thought was great that I really
gravitated to and so the guy came up
afterward and was like would you like to
read it was my script that you liked and
I read it and I just thought it was
really fantastic he's a great writer and
I was I remember reading it and it was
an action script and I don't typically
write action so I'm it was so crisp and
it was just moving so quickly and I was
like I just love how he's he's
structured this and how you know even on
the page the way it looks just so
conducive to what he was trying to
convey in terms of the content the I I
was like I've got to remember so I was
as I was reading that I was absorbing
all that you know because he may not be
as far on his journey as I am he is
certainly a better action writer than I
am and so I was learning a lot from how
he he structured his and the words he
chose yeah and that's where you were
talking about earlier I'm not sure what
the word was bitterness but that's where
you get that chance to either take it
from bitterness so wow what can I learn
and how can I do something similar yeah
you can learn from everyone and that's
the thing there's so many people who I
think people just want to feel validated
so badly that they get to a place where
they're like I'm the expert and
everyone's just be listening to what I
have to say about this and that's it's
kind of crazy because yeah you may have
put your 10,000 hours and you may be
very good at what you do but you can
learn something from everything that you
read even learning what not to do but
even in in really bad scripts you'll
find these little moments where I'm like
oh my gosh that was really well conveyed
or you know so just being open to those
things and learning from other people
because people are constantly adding to
this body of work that exists in the
world and there's so much for you to be
able to read out there just you know be
open to what other people are doing I
but then again you have to love reading
so many writers don't
reading so you know read read read read
and see what other people are doing a
lot of people want to start writing
without ever having read a script and I
just I don't understand it
are you also reading novels too or not
when I have time I don't have a lot of
time yeah but yeah when I get the chance
you know I love to read novels yeah it's
such a lost art I miss it too and it's
really hard in today's world because so
much amazing content is on YouTube so we
can learn it even faster by watching a
video but I miss the act of reading and
it's it's a lost yeah it is and even I
mean I even get caught up sometimes in
reading nonfiction because I feel like
okay at least I'm learning more than if
I'm reading a novel but you have to
remember you are learning you're
learning you're by getting caught up in
it and seeing how that writer has taken
you through this flow of their words you
know you're learning a lot by just doing
that - that you can then bring to screen
writing as well do you believe in
screenplay structure I do I believe in
the three-act structure I believe in
learning the rules so that you can then
break the rules but there is an
acceptable structure to storytelling and
there's a reason it works and I think if
you can get really good at that
so good that then you can manipulate it
that serves you what was one of the
first books on screenwriting that you
read um I think the Syd field book
because it was required reading for at
USC film school but but it's still a
fantastic book and I think I actually
still have it in my library oh nice okay
when you're writing dialogue are you
rules for it the same or it really
depends because of the character or even
the producer you know what they want it
depends yeah a lot of it is knowing what
the producer wants but a lot of it also
is just finding the character's voice
you know one of the mistakes a lot of
screenwriters make is that they all the
all the characters sound exactly alike
you should be able to you know block out
the character name and know who's
talking and you know you can learn a lot
about
how people speak just by sort of
listening like listening in coffee shops
to how people talk and stuff people
rarely are some very self-reflective
people rarely say exactly what they mean
people rarely talk in complete sentences
and so you know the words we choose when
you think about when you go to say
something there's probably a hundred
different ways you could think of to say
it why are you choosing the particular
way you you choose and when you start to
think like that and why your character
is choosing to say something that way
and what they really don't want to
reveal like why ye will they go to this
length but they won't go just a little
bit more vulnerable when you kind of
understand that about your character
then I think writing the dialogue
becomes easier but you have to put that
thought process into it first to know
what they want to conceal and what they
want to to give I think and then and
then you can start working with the
subtext and all that kind of stuff that
makes all of that flavor kind of come
out would you say a lot of the
productions or the networks that you're
writing for are heavy on dialogue just
because I mean the nature of women and
we tend to talk more especially with
other women like it that's we kind of
get together and talk yeah heavy dial I
think well the genres tend to be heavier
on dialogue I think also you know when
you're when you are doing a very
contained like a low budget that has a
lot to do with it too because a lot of
times the people are sitting and talking
right you're in a room you're in a house
or whatever so they're sitting and
talking but I think making sure that
that pacing is good so it just doesn't
feel like really you know people just
explaining things that's kind of the
death of people's dialogue is when
people over explain and they don't know
how to sort of weave in that that
exposition kind of nicely then it really
just kind of like hangs there that's
that's not good writing so hopefully
there's not much of that that you're
watching on television when you're
watching that well just as you said you
know sort of the the tone of the culture
has changed has a tone of conversation
in how you got it changed I think it has
I think that people are actually it's
it's less than it used to be because I
think people
want things to happen very quickly you
know like the two-minute video versus
the seven-minute video wait so they want
to get through this and the pacing has
to be much more quick than it used to be
so scenes are shorter and so you get to
the point much more quickly I think that
has changed over time I'm hoping to get
your thoughts on finishing this sentence
and that sentence is even when you walk
out of the best film school upon
graduation you are oh you're just
another person with a dream really
that's it I think you know being 19 20
years old you don't I didn't know what
to do with the best film school
education in the country right I was
just a 19 year old skipping class half
the time you know not really realizing
what I was being given until later so
you know but in hindsight is 2020 so but
you come out of film school it's still
still about you it's still about what
you're gonna make of that education
because all the education in the world
and understanding how to write a
screenplay does nothing for you if
you're not willing to sit down and put
the work in interesting how how long
after did you did you have that
realization I think that realization
came when I took those that six months I
think because I really until then I
don't think I was working hard I just
thought it was gonna come to me you know
and then I realized I've I've gotten off
track I've got to do this I've got to do
this and that's when I that's when I
realized it when did you go back for
your masters I was I was a lot older I
was in my 30s when I went back for my
masters and so it's in juvenile
delinquency I think I'm gonna lie my
master's degree is in criminal justice
and I focused on juvenile delinquency
and cyber crime Wow
what was just curious what prompted that
because that's a fascinating I've always
been interested in it and then I think
because I was just writing so many crime
dramas and and crime thrillers that I
thought at one point I thought how can I
be a better crime writer because that's
really what I am and I made a list of
things and on that list was get a
master's degree and so I did that and
also on that list was to go through one
of the citizens academies for the police
department which I did that so I learned
so much from all of those things on that
list and you apply that now to the
stories and also to in terms of the the
victim and maybe their reaction or their
falling prey to someone absol in in my
criminal justice program we actually
took a victimology class which I didn't
know that even existed that there's a
whole study of how victims are treated
by the system how they react the proper
way to deal with them primary and
secondary victims and all of these types
of things I didn't know anything about
that so that was a big eye-opener to
just learning that type of stuff and
then also being able to sort of condense
that material and use it to help other
writers who are because it's very
difficult to research like I can't call
a probation officer and say hey I've got
a character who skips probation can you
tell me how to do that like they're
never gonna tell you that because you
might have a brother who's trying to do
that so so that's very hard stuff to
research so by getting the degree gave
me some legitimacy also because everyone
in my class was in law enforcement they
know am an actual screenwriter now I can
actually call them and say I need your
help with this so that was actually a
big help too that was completely
unintended interesting wow so
victimology that's incredible and so
that plays a lot into a lot of the
stories in terms of people wanting to
believe someone's good I mean because I
think we all can see ourselves as
victims mm-hmm in a lot of ways and and
but I know that that's a big part of
certain stories and that that you you
have good intentions and then you're
duped kind of thing it was just it's not
just that there there's also
and this is where you know we get into a
lot of political correctness when we try
to have these conversations and we
shouldn't because we need to have honest
conversations about them but at what
level do victims play a part in being
victimized you know there are certain
people who will never be victimized and
there are certain people who are
victimized over and over and over and
you know and again you know we we get so
caught up in trying to just convey this
idea that it's not the victims fault
it's the perpetrators fault when
something happens they were the ones
that made the choice to commit the crime
the victim was the victim which is
important but there but what is it about
certain people and their mannerisms and
their choices that make them fall victim
when other people have it and so a lot
of it is studying that which I find
incredibly interesting also and so
you've been able to use that and it
sounds like a lot of the characters that
you write yeah I try to incorporate a
lot of that kind of stuff just to give
it the authenticity that I think it
should have and and I try to bring up
some of those questions right these
ideas at least let people think about
them as you know even if we don't we
don't make a concise statement about
them that there's this idea that you
could be semi responsible for what's
happening to you so I try to bring this
up and then let people talk about those
things later on so I looked at your IMDB
and is the first credit writing credit
the perfect nanny with Tracy Nelson and
I thought yes that is the first one yeah
okay great so how is that the one that
you had from doing the rewrite and then
the producer wanted to hire you um no I
got fired off that process
oh no yeah I that was with a producer
who I was working as an assistant in
development and then left he sold the
company I left was working then as a
reader for a little bit and then he
invited me to come back and do this
rewrite which I did and I think I did
two drafts and they hired another writer
which is fine if I mean at the time I
was sort of sad about it but it was a
great learning experience because I
didn't know what I didn't know right and
so now looking back to see where I've
grown where
I'm now the last rider on because I you
know that was it was good for me to go
through that experience and I was very
grateful that he gave me the opportunity
even to do that one because that ended
up me my first credit okay so the one
that you were fired off with maybe not
giving away too much information but did
you see what it was or was it something
that was out of your control no I just
wasn't a good enough writer to do what
they needed me to do okay so I I did
improve the script and a lot of what I
put in there ended up in the final cut
but I think I just didn't know structure
well enough to be able to fix some of
the issues that they had that they
needed me to fix and so I fixed the
character stuff and then I think they
hired another writer to fix all the
structural stuff that was wrong with it
and so at that time did you see it as
structure like a structural defect or no
no I did I couldn't recognize that at
that time yes
so then once you probably were excellent
at structure then you saw that's what it
was yeah and I think it's also just over
time understanding getting to know more
what what they want when they tell you
we need this or we want this what that
means and how to incorporate that into a
screenplay you know why we want to add
edge to this it's not edgy enough that's
a very obscure you know idea so hearing
that when I was that early in my career
I don't think I understood how to
implement edge and now when someone says
that okay now I understand the questions
to ask so I can tell me what they really
want and I understand what they mean by
that so it's just over time I've learned
what that means so if it's let's suppose
it's a housewife that has everything
perfect and nothing's wrong how would
you incorporate some edge into that
because I'm picturing that as the
Lifetime movie that I knew which was so
interesting but what edge would we add
two legends they might have like a dark
secret or a fetish or something in their
past that they feel ashamed of that
they've kept from their husband so
something like that the the is sort of
just kind of lurking in the background
this seems to sort of resurface and
doesn't even have to be part of the a
story it can be something that just
complicates the a story right so you
know she like let's say your housewife
they're been trying to get pregnant
she's finally gotten pregnant and she
has this ex-boyfriend who is getting out
of prison and still wants to be with her
and so now he's gonna come back and
complicate her life and that may not be
the a story but it's something that now
she has to tell her husband who this
person is and bla bla right right and
there's the edge and there's edge right
so there's the intrigue to that so it's
it's adding - it's just it's it's
rounding out that story right and making
people real because everybody has things
that they're not proud of or whatever
and so this is something that you can
add those and we can go even further you
know in the Lifetime movies or TV movies
with that kind of stuff so is the aim to
show sort of perfection and then as we
said before backing out and then seeing
that it's not perfect I don't know if
it's to show perfection I think a lot of
what intrigues people are the pretenses
right I think so much of what we try to
do even with Facebook is to show
everybody in the world what this great
life we have what every great you know
you don't take the picture of the crappy
ramen noodles you made last night cuz
you're so tired to cook you take it when
you're at a nice restaurant right look
at as beautiful or this thing that you
made and you spent hours on we put out a
life that we want other people to see
because that's what we think they're
forming their opinions of us the irony
is that most people care more about
themselves and they care about anyone
else anyway so they're not even forming
those opinions but that's what we do our
characters are the same thing
you know our characters live lives based
on what they think they should be living
right and so that's why it's kind of fun
when you can you can flush these
characters out and give them these
things in their past or things that
they're doing or temptations or whatever
you know that cause those little things
of conflicts right and they always have
to have a great place to live and all
the life time I mean I've never seen a
woman and a lifetime movie live in a bad
place that was never happy
there's definitely an escapism element
to that as well
this is sort of a standard question but
it always gets great answers best piece
of advice and what was it and worse
pieces of advice and what was it oh no
one named names the best piece of advice
I got was from a professor in film
school and he said do what you love and
the money will come and I know that I
mean he that's not his quote but it was
the first time I had heard it and I
think it's very important to remember to
keep doing what you love and the money
will come don't focus on the money
because when you start focusing on the
money you make decisions that aren't
necessarily the ones you'd make based on
love so that to me was the best piece of
advice the worst piece of advice was
probably you don't have to change
anything it's your script and you know
there is always this thing about how
much should you change you know before
you're selling out how much should you
change that a producer wanting to change
it how much did you fight for your own
vision my feeling on that is you can
fight on the next one sell the script
right and get the credit and get the
money and at some point as you kind of
progress through your career you get
more and more power and then you have to
change less and less so but you got to
get there first so early in your career
do what they need you to do make them
happy you're the client
though the client I mean it's you know
do what they want and and make the
changes you know if you can stick to two
you're your own creative vision on the
next one so with both pieces of advice
did you agree or disagree with them
right away or did it take some time it
took time and you know very early in my
career I did that I pull the script away
it was actually my thesis script that I
wrote in film school I had a producer
interested in buying it and after he
gave me the notes I was convinced he
didn't get the project he just doesn't
understand it
pulled the script away and I ended up
never selling that script and I don't
know if it would have made any
difference in how my career went or not
because you just you don't know but in
retrospect that was me being a prima
donna and thinking that I knew more and
once that happened that experience
happened I lost that attitude which
probably served me very well for the
rest of my career so I kind of hope that
most writers have that experience early
on because that will help them and then
with the best piece oh do what you love
the money well I mean I'm thinking of
the book of this Virginia Virginia sign
tar or something I think I have that
book actually at home and I read it too
because I was in a place where I didn't
know but but did you because I had
trouble believing that concept it's it's
hard to believe that concept right well
I heard it so young that I actually did
believe it initially because when you're
in college you're not jaded yeah you
haven't actually been in the real world
but but you do lose it you absolutely
lose it because you know when the money
starts to not come you the first thing
you do is question that right and you
start to compromise and but the reality
is even through all those difficult
periods and and they will happen
especially if you're a writer especially
if you're freelance than anything stick
to what you love because it will it will
happen it will happen and you just have
to to keep the faith
I know it's hard it really is but my
life is proving it I feel like and I
think if you stick with it long enough
almost everybody's life will prove that